When Jeffrey was 22 he had this rare problem with his eyes, and doctors had to use lasers to fix vessels that were bleeding at the back of his left eye which worked great. But not long after, on a cold, bright winter day, he came into his house from the cold and saw this color.
杰弗里22岁时眼睛出了个罕见的问题，医生不得不使用激光修复他左眼后部出血的血管，手术效果非常好。但没过多久，在一个寒冷明亮的冬日，他从外面回到家，看到了这种颜色。
And it was almost like an afterimage, like when you look at a bright light. And it was a blind spot right where they had put the lasers. And instead of seeing blackness, it was this greenish not-green. It was like a green that could never exist. And it was fluorescent. And it was kind of pulsating and staticky.
这几乎就像是一种残像，就像你盯着强光看之后产生的那种。那是一个盲点，正好在他做激光手术的地方。他看到的不是一片漆黑，而是一种绿色的非绿色。就像一种本不该存在的绿色。它是荧光的，还在不停地跳动、闪烁，像静电一样。
Got that? Green, but not green.
听明白了吗？绿色，但又不是绿色。
You know, actually maybe a better way of describing, it was like if the color black was fluorescent and green.
你知道，其实更好的描述方式是，它就像如果黑色本身具有荧光，而且是绿色的。
Wait. I'm just going to say those words back to you. If the color black were fluorescent and green.
等等。我把你刚才说的话重复一遍。如果黑色本身具有荧光，而且是绿色的。
Yeah.
对。
You know that sounds crazy, right?
你知道这听起来很疯狂，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah.
对，没错。
You know how some colors seem more energetic, like bright red or bright yellow, and others are more peaceful, like sort of a blue-green sea color? Which is this?
你知道有些颜色显得更有活力，比如亮红或亮黄，而有些则更平和，比如那种蓝绿色的海洋色？这是哪一种？
It was both. It was both energetic and calming.
两者兼有。既充满活力又令人平静。
But a lot of the color is greenish, right? It's in the kind of green family?
但这种颜色大部分是绿色的，对吧？属于绿色系的？
Yeah, it is greenish. I remember I bought a bunch of markers a while ago trying to find a way of representing it to my doctor.
对，是偏绿色的。我记得很久以前我买了一堆记号笔，试图找到一种方法把它呈现给医生看。
And so if you were to try to paint it or draw it, you would start with a kind of fluorescent green, right?
所以，如果你要试着画出来，你会先用一种荧光绿作为基底，对吧？
Mhm.
嗯。
And then what would you add to it to add the other part that is not green?
那你还要加点什么，才能补上那部分“非绿色”的特质呢？
Black and, like, fireworks.
黑色，还有像烟花一样的感觉。
You just said black and fireworks?
你刚才说黑色和烟花？
Yeah.
对。
He said that if you've ever had a migraine headache, it can come with a kind of colorful, sparkly static. It was like that. Fireworks. But really, he said, he's never done a good job describing this. How do you describe a color that only you have seen?
他说，如果你曾经偏头痛过，那种症状会伴随一种五彩斑斓的闪烁静电。就是那种感觉。烟花。但他真的说，他从来没能很好地描述过这种感觉。你该怎么去描述一种只有你见过的人眼中的颜色呢？
OK, which of these things would you say about this color? Does it remind you of the feeling of punching somebody in the face, or more like a soft kiss from somebody who you're just falling in love with, or more like warm toast and butter on a cold morning?
好的，关于这种颜色，你会选以下哪种形容？它让你想起被人迎面打了一拳的感觉，还是像陷入热恋时得到的一个轻吻，又或是寒冷清晨里温热的涂黄油吐司？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
You know, I have to say, of those three options you give me, I think I only have lots of experience with the third.
你知道，我必须说，在你给出的这三个选项里，我觉得我只有第三种体验丰富。
And does the color remind you of that one?
那这种颜色让你想起那个感觉了吗？
You said warm toast and butter on a cold morning?
你说的是寒冷清晨的涂黄油吐司？
Yeah.
对。
No.
没有。
The color, does it remind you of the feeling of hope, or more a feeling of existential dread?
那这种颜色让你想起希望的感觉，还是更偏向于一种存在主义的恐惧？
Existential dread.
存在主义的恐惧。
The color, does it remind you at all of the feeling that you get when you're a kid and you get either a Ho-Ho or a Ding Dong, and it's sort of cool and so the outside shell of it is perfectly hard, and you bite into it and it cracks open and it's soft and chocolaty underneath?
这种颜色，有没有让你想起小时候吃Ho-Ho或Ding Dong蛋糕时的那种感觉？那种因为冷藏过，外壳变得又硬又完美，咬下去裂开，露出里面柔软又浓郁的巧克力心的感觉？
Um, no.
嗯，没有。
The color, does it remind you of the feeling of somebody's going to cook something for you, and you don't really know if they're a good cook or bad cook, and then it turns out they're just an amazing cook. And everything you eat, you think, this is a very good version of this particular thing that I'm eating?
这种颜色，有没有让你想起这种感觉：有人要为你做顿饭，你其实不知道对方厨艺好坏，结果发现他们竟然是个大厨，你吃的每一口都会想：“我吃的这道菜简直是目前为止最好的版本。”
Yeah, you know, Ira, it was a little bit more mundane than that.
是的，艾拉，其实比那还要平凡得多。
When you see something that nobody else can see, it can be terrifying. And Jeffrey was scared that maybe something was seriously deteriorating with his vision. But once it became clear that he was going to be fine and he was going to be able to see, he had this other impulse-- to show his friends. To share it.
当你看到别人看不见的东西时，那可能会很吓人。杰弗里当时很害怕，担心自己的视力出现了严重的退化。但一旦确定自己不会有事，视力也能保住，他便产生了另一个冲动——向朋友炫耀，想和别人分享。
Well, yeah. I used to make drawings of it. I used to make drawings of the shapes. Like, I used a black pen and then I did the outline in that fluorescent. And you know, it's like, yeah, I'd show it to my friends and they didn't get it. They didn't think it was that neat.
哦，对。我以前常画它。我会画那些形状。比如，我用黑色钢笔画轮廓，然后用那种荧光色填充。你知道，我会给朋友看，但他们根本不理解。他们觉得那没什么意思。
[LAUGHS] What would they say?
[笑] 他们会说什么？
Oh, man. Usually what I get is, "that's interesting."
噢，伙计。通常我得到的回答都是：“挺有意思的。”
Ugh. That's the worst.
额，那是最糟糕的评价。
Yeah.
对。
Of course, when you see something that other people can't, you're stuck. I think for most people, you want to tell somebody. You want to share it. You want to do something.
当然，当你看到别人看不见的东西时，你就会陷入困境。我想对大多数人来说，你都想告诉别人。你想分享它。你想做点什么。
Today no our program, we have three stories of people in this exact situation-- one involving science, one involving comedy, one involving angels. These people see something nobody else can and they cannot stop themselves. They can't shut up about it.
今天我们的节目有三个关于处于这种境遇的人的故事——一个涉及科学，一个涉及喜剧，还有一个涉及天使。这些人看到了没人能看到的东西，他们无法自拔。他们对此喋喋不休。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Do These Genes Make Me Look Fatless?
第一幕，是基因让我看起来没有赘肉吗？
Well, let's kick things off with this story of somebody who not only sees something that nobody else sees, when she tells other people about the stuff she see, they don't buy it. Investigative reporter David Epstein explains.
那么，我们先从这个故事开始：一个不仅看到了别人看不到的东西，而且当她告诉别人她所看到的东西时，别人根本不相信她的女人。调查记者大卫·爱泼斯坦来为你讲述。
I wrote a book called The Sports Gene. It's partly about how some super-athletes are genetically different from the rest of us. They have super genes. They're physiological freaks.
我写过一本书叫《运动基因》。它部分讲述了顶尖运动员在基因上与我们其他人有何不同。他们拥有超强基因。他们是生理上的怪物。
I was deluged with emails from parents wanting to know how they could find out if their child had Michael Jordan genes. A coach wrote offering up his players as guinea pigs for genetic experimentation. There were so many unhinged email coming in that I pretty much stopped opening them.
我被那些想知道如何查询孩子是否拥有乔丹基因的家长们的邮件淹没了。有教练写信提议把他的队员作为基因实验的小白鼠。那些疯狂的邮件实在太多了，我几乎停止了查阅。
And then I got this one that had the subject heading, "Olympic Medalist and Muscular Dystrophy Patient with the Same Mutation" I opened it, figuring it would be a link to some article that I'd missed in my reporting. Instead, it was a note from a 39-year-old Iowa mother. Her name was Jill Viles. She was the muscular dystrophy patient, and she had a wild theory linking her genes to an Olympic sprinter named Priscilla Lopes-Schliep, and she wanted to send more info.
然后我收到了这一封，主题是“奥运奖牌得主与肌营养不良症患者携带同种变异基因”。我打开了它，以为那是链接到我报道中遗漏的某篇文章。结果，那是一位来自爱荷华州的39岁母亲的来信。她叫吉尔·瓦尔斯。她是那个肌营养不良症患者，她有一个疯狂的理论，将自己的基因与一位名叫普里西拉·洛佩斯-施利普的奥运短跑选手联系在了一起，她想发送更多信息。
Sure, I said. Send it along. Why not?
“当然，”我说，“发过来看看。为什么不呢？”
Days later, a package arrived-- a 19-page illustrated bound packet. I thumbed through it. It was a little weird-- hand-drawn diagrams with cutouts of little cartoon weightlifters representing protein molecules, old photos of herself and her siblings, the original pictures, not copies. There was a detailed medical history, and it was clear she knew some serious science. She described in detail how proteins function. She referred to gene mutations by their specific DNA addresses, the way a scientist would.
几天后，包裹到了——一个19页的图文并茂的装订册。我翻了翻。这有点怪——手绘图表里剪贴着卡通举重运动员代表蛋白质分子，还有她和她兄弟姐妹的老照片，原件，不是复印件。里面有详细的病史，很显然她懂一些深奥的科学。她详细描述了蛋白质的功能。她像科学家一样，用特定的DNA地址指代基因突变。
And then I landed on page 14. There were two photos-- one of Jill in a royal blue bikini, sitting on a beach. Her torso looks normal, but her arms, it's like they're on the wrong body, like the stick arms on a snowman. Her legs, too, are so thin that her knee joint is wider than her thigh. Those legs can't possibly hold her upright, I thought.
然后我翻到了第14页。有两张照片——一张是吉尔穿着宝蓝色比基尼坐在沙滩上。她的躯干看起来很正常，但手臂就像是安错了身体，像雪人手臂那样的细棍。她的双腿也细得离谱，膝关节比大腿还要宽。我想，那样的腿怎么可能撑得住她的身体？
The other picture was of Priscilla Lopes-Schlip, who'd been ranked the best hurdler in the world. In 2008, she won the bronze medal in the 100-meter hurdles at the Olympics in Beijing. In the photo, she's in mid-stride. It's hard to describe just how muscular she looks. Picture all the muscle you can imagine on a woman. Now picture more.
另一张照片是曾排名世界第一的跨栏选手普里西拉·洛佩斯-施利普。在2008年北京奥运会上，她获得了100米栏铜牌。照片中，她正处于跨栏瞬间。很难描述她看起来有多强壮。想象一下你能想象到一个女性身上所有的肌肉，然后再翻个倍。
In that photo, Priscilla's like the vision of a superhero that a third-grader might draw-- huge muscles bursting from her thighs, like her skin can barely contain all of the power beneath it; ropey veins snaking along her biceps. This is the woman Jill believed she shared the same genetic code with. Jill, remember, whose arms and legs are like sticks.
在那张照片里，普里西拉就像三年级小学生画里的超级英雄——大腿上肌肉虬结，皮肤仿佛快要包不住里面喷薄而出的力量，肱二头肌上蛇形蜿蜒着粗壮的血管。这就是吉尔认为与自己共享同一基因密码的女人。记住，吉尔的手臂和腿像细棍一样。
But look at Lopes-Schlip. She's coming. Priscilla Lopes-Schliep making a move. To the finish she goes, and she will surge across that line. A world-leading time of 12:52.
看，洛佩斯-施利普来了。普里西拉·洛佩斯-施利普正在发力。冲向终点，她跨过了那条线。12秒52，世界领先水平的成绩。
All Jill's life, doctors had been mystified by her case. They had no idea how her muscle disease worked, much less how to treat it. She did know her disease came from a rare genetic mutation. And she wanted to reach Priscilla, because, looking at photos of Priscilla, seeing her body, she saw clues that made her believe Priscilla had the same mutation. If Priscilla did, if Jill was right, then scientists might figure out what was making Jill's muscles shrink and Priscilla's muscles balloon. And maybe people like Jill could someday be helped.
吉尔一生都被医生困惑。他们不知道她的肌肉病是怎么回事，更不知道如何治疗。她确实知道她的病源于一种罕见的基因突变。她想联系普里西拉，因为看着普里西拉的照片，看着她的身体，她看到了线索，让她相信普里西拉携带相同的突变。如果普里西拉确实如此，如果吉尔是对的，那么科学家们就能找出导致吉尔肌肉萎缩而普里西拉肌肉膨胀的原因。或许像吉尔这样的人有朝一日能得到帮助。
The whole thing seemed like a long shot, so I reached out to Robert Green, a geneticist at Harvard who I got to know while writing my book. He's an important proponent of people being allowed to get their own genetic tests. But after looking at the pictures of Jill and Priscilla, he thought Jill was almost certainly wrong. He doubted they had anything in common. And science aside, he had other concerns.
这一切看起来机会渺茫，所以我联系了我在写书时认识的哈佛遗传学家罗伯特·格林。他是支持人们进行自主基因检测的重要倡导者。但在看了吉尔和普里西拉的照片后，他认为吉尔几乎肯定错了。他怀疑她们之间没有任何共同点。撇开科学不谈，他还有其他担忧。
For one thing, a somewhat famous athlete, just like any other celebrity, can become the focal point for an individual for various reasons in a very unhealthy way. I was concerned that empowering a relationship between these two women could end badly, yeah. I mean, people go off the deep end when they're relating to celebrities they think they have a connection to.
首先，一个稍有名气的运动员，就像任何其他名人一样，可能会出于各种原因成为某个人眼中极不健康的核心关注点。我担心赋予这两个女人建立联系的动力可能会以悲剧收场。我的意思是，当人们试图与他们认为自己有某种联系的名人相处时，往往会走向极端。
Of course, this is a very polite way of saying, maybe she's a nut job. I wondered the same thing. How could you not? The idea that an Iowa housewife working off Google Images would make a medical discovery about a professional athlete, whose body has been obsessively examined for years by a small army of doctors and athletic trainers, it seemed pretty ludicrous. But the fact is people with MDs and PhDs have been telling Jill that her theories are ludicrous pretty much her whole life.
当然，这是委婉的说法，意思可能是：她可能是个疯子。我也纳闷。怎么可能不纳闷呢？一个靠谷歌图片搜索的爱荷华州家庭主妇居然对一名职业运动员做出了医学发现，而那个运动员的身体多年来一直被一小支医生和教练团队痴迷地检查过——这看起来太荒谬了。但事实是，拥有医学博士和哲学博士头衔的人几乎一生都在告诉吉尔，她的理论是荒谬的。
Jill was born in 1974. At first, everything was great. She met all the normal baby milestones. She sat, crawled, and walked on time. Then at age four, she started stumbling and tripping all the time, constantly falling flat on her face.
吉尔出生于1974年。起初，一切都很正常。她达到了所有的婴儿成长里程碑。按时坐立、爬行和走路。然后到了四岁，她开始频繁地绊倒和摔跤，总是摔个狗吃屎。
I would describe this fear I had about witches' fingers.
我会描述我内心对“女巫手指”的恐惧。
This is Jill.
这是吉尔。
And my mom was kind of puzzled. What was I talking about, witches' fingers? What do you mean? And when we'd walk, I'd felt this sensation, almost like there were little-- there were gnarled hands and fingers reaching up and grabbing my shins, and I'd fall really forcefully. That was kind of the beginning of noticing something was different.
我妈妈很困惑。我说的“女巫手指”是什么意思？什么意思？走路的时候，我会感觉到一种触感，就像有小小的……有扭曲的手和手指伸出来抓我的小腿，然后我会重重地摔倒。那就是我开始意识到有什么不对劲的开端。
Jill's dad remembered that he'd had some problems walking around the same age, which his doctors had said was the result of a very mild case of polio. But Jill's troubles were much worse than her dad's had ever been. And no one could give them an answer.
吉尔的父亲记得他在同样年纪走路也有困难，医生说是轻微小儿麻痹症的结果。但吉尔的麻烦比她父亲严重得多。没人能给出一个答案。
Her pediatrician was stumped. He suggested they take her to the Mayo Clinic. They were stumped there, too. They tested the whole family, and found that Jill and her brother and her dad all had signs of muscle damage. But Jill was the only one having trouble walking. It might be muscular dystrophy, the doctors thought, but that didn't usually show up this way in little girls.
她的儿科医生被难住了。建议他们去梅奥诊所。那边也被难住了。他们检查了全家，发现吉尔、她哥哥和她父亲都有肌肉损伤的迹象。但只有吉尔走路困难。医生认为可能是肌营养不良，但这通常不会在小女孩身上这样表现。
They were really, really sure they'd never seen anything like this. They said our family was extremely unique. And they couldn't define what type it was. Ultimately, that's good in one way because they're being honest.
他们非常非常确定从未见过这样的病例。他们说我们的家庭非常独特。他们无法定义是什么类型。归根结底，从某种角度看是好事，因为他们很诚实。
But on the other hand, it was terrifying. What is my life expectancy? What are the symptoms that I'll be dealing with? It's alarming if you don't have something to grasp a hold of.
但另一方面，这太恐怖了。我的预期寿命是多少？我将面对什么样的症状？如果没有任何可以依附的东西，这让人惊慌。
Jill went back to the Mayo Clinic every year, and it was always the same. There was nothing the doctors could do, nothing new they could tell her. The constant falling eventually stopped, but it was replaced by a burning sensation in her legs. And while she was growing in height like a normal girl, the fat on her arms and legs was vanishing.
吉尔每年都去梅奥诊所，结果总是没变。医生什么也做不了，没有任何新进展可以告诉她。频繁摔倒最终停止了，但取而代之的是腿部的灼烧感。虽然她像正常女孩一样长高，但手臂和腿上的脂肪却消失了。
By the time she was eight, her arms and legs were so skinny that other kids could wrap their fingers around her wrists and ankles. By age 12, veins were popping out of her legs. Kids asked how it felt to be old. And then her muscles started to fail again.
八岁时，她的手臂和腿太瘦了，其他孩子可以用手掌包住她的手腕和脚踝。12岁时，腿部血管爆出。孩子们问她老了是什么感觉。然后她的肌肉开始再次衰竭。
I could remember just getting on a bike I'd always ridden and feeling like someone came up behind me and just threw me into the handlebars, and got a big bruise across my chest from-- I'd fall so hard. I couldn't hold myself over the bike. My muscles would just start quivering.
我记得骑上一辆我一直骑的自行车，感觉就像有人从背后走过来，猛地把我扔向车把手，胸前一大块淤青——我摔得太重了。我无法在车上保持平衡。我的肌肉开始颤抖。
And roller skating-- I invited a friend to go with me, and I can't even stand up on the skates. And I'm just sitting there going, something's terribly wrong.
还有溜冰——我邀请朋友一起去，我甚至没法在溜冰鞋上站起来。我坐在那里想，有什么地方出大问题了。
How rapid? How quick was that, that you basically lost the ability to roller skate and ride your bike?
有多快？你基本上失去了溜冰和骑车的能力，那是多快发生的？
I would say probably within a few weeks.
我想大概几周之内。
Jill didn't even bother to tell her parents what was happening. She knew there was nothing there the doctors could do about it. By the end of that summer, the symptoms eased up. She could walk OK again. She started looking for answers on her own, but she did it the way a kid would.
吉尔甚至没去告诉父母发生了什么。她知道医生在那方面无计可施。那个夏天结束时，症状缓解了。她走路又正常了。她开始自己寻找答案，但用的方式还是孩子的那种。
You know, I'm having my body do things that I can't control. Forces are acting on me. And I developed curiosity, fascination with things, like I would read about poltergeists. And I would bring home lots of books from the library. I remember it really freaked out my dad at one point, because he tipped over my book bag and there's all these books about supernatural things. And he was like, what are you into the occult or what? And it was nothing of the sort.
你知道，我的身体在做一些我无法控制的事情。力量在作用于我。我产生了好奇心，对各种事物着迷，比如我会读关于“骚灵现象”的东西。我会从图书馆带回很多书。我记得有一次这把我爸吓坏了，他把我的书包翻过来，全是关于超自然现象的书。他说：“你是在研究什么邪教吗？”根本不是那回事。
It was about, I couldn't explain what was going on with me. The doctors couldn't explain. And I found these people that people couldn't explain what was happening to them totally fascinating. I believe them.
是因为我无法解释自己身上发生了什么。医生也无法解释。我发现这些无法解释自己遭遇的人非常迷人。我相信他们。
By the time she went to college, Jill had maxed out at 5'3" and about 87 pounds. She decided that if she was going to figure out what was happening with her body, she'd have to do it herself. So during Jill's first semester, she set up camp in the library. She began poring over every textbook and scientific journal article she could find on different kinds of muscle disease.
上大学时，吉尔的身高定格在5英尺3英寸，体重约87磅。她决定如果她要弄清楚身体发生了什么，就必须亲自去调查。所以吉尔在大一学期期间，就在图书馆扎了营。她开始埋头苦读能找到的关于各种肌肉疾病的所有教科书和医学期刊文章。
So I just thought, well, I'll start reading about them one by one and see if something fits.
所以我当时想，好吧，我要一本一本地读，看看哪一种匹配。
She did this for months, going article by article, like a police officer driving up and down every street doing a grid search. But nothing really fit, until she came to a page in a medical journal about an extremely rare type of muscular dystrophy called Emery-Dreifuss.
她这样做持续了几个月，逐一排查，就像警察在每条街上来回巡视进行地毯式搜索。但没有完全吻合的，直到她读到一本医学期刊上关于一种极其罕见的肌营养不良症，叫“埃默里-德雷福斯型（Emery-Dreifuss）”。
And then looking at the pictures, it was a very startling thing to realize, I'm seeing my dad's arm-- just an instantaneous lock on something that's in your visual memory.
看到照片时，意识到“我看到了我父亲的手臂”，那是一种非常令人震惊的事情——就像视觉记忆中被瞬间锁定了。
Well, what did you see?
嗯，你看到了什么？
As a little girl, I would notice he had what I called Popeye arms-- big forearms and hand muscles. And then as I'm reading about Emery-Dreifuss, they actually describe the look of the arms as a Popeye-arm deformity. But there were very, very few photos of women with Emery-Dreifuss muscular dystrophy.
作为一个小女孩，我注意到他有我称之为“大力水手手臂”——粗壮的前臂和手部肌肉。然后在读关于埃默里-德雷福斯的文章时，他们真的把手臂的样子描述为“大力水手手臂畸形”。但患有埃默里-德雷福斯肌营养不良症的女性照片非常非常少。
The journal described the three hallmarks of Emery-Dreifuss patients. They couldn't touch their chins to their chests, or their heels to the floor, and their arms were perpetually bent at the elbow.
期刊描述了埃默里-德雷福斯患者的三个标志性症状：下巴碰不到胸部，脚后跟落不到地板，手臂永远保持肘部弯曲。
And I'm getting chills reading this, thinking, well, I've got all three. A really great visual to think about that is, shockingly, a Barbie doll.
我读到这里起鸡皮疙瘩，心想，好吧，这三点我全中。对此一个极其形象的对比是：芭比娃娃。
That is, elbows that don't bend and feet slanted to fit into high heels.
也就是说，肘部无法伸直，脚部为了穿高跟鞋而倾斜。
Actually, it's a terrific representation of what does Emery-Dreifuss look like, which is very ironic because we give this to little girls and say, this is perfect. And we're actually handing them a doll that has a genetic disorder.
事实上，这是一个关于埃默里-德雷福斯看起来像什么的绝佳代表，这非常讽刺，因为我们把它送给小女孩并说：这很完美。而我们其实是送给她们一个患有遗传病的娃娃。
So when you flip open and you see these pictures and see these descriptions, is it like the light bulb just flipped on and this is it?
所以当你翻开书看到这些照片和描述时，就像灯泡点亮了，这就是它吗？
The light bulb. I was sure. It's eerie. It's great, but it's terrifying. What was very frightening was to read there's a lot of cardiac issues involved with this disease.
灯泡。我很确定。这太离奇了。这很棒，但也太恐怖了。最令人恐惧的是读到这种病涉及许多心脏问题。
Emery-Dreifuss patients, Jill learned, often dropped dead of heart failure. She became obsessed with reading about it. Before she went home for college break, she stuffed her bag full of medical books and journal articles.
吉尔了解到，埃默里-德雷福斯患者经常会死于心脏衰竭。她变得痴迷于此。寒假回家前，她把装满医学书籍和期刊文章的包塞满。
I purposely even hid them under several books because I didn't want to alarm anybody at home. And I went out in the kitchen long enough to make microwave popcorn. And I came back in and my dad was reading them. And I tried to take them away. And I'm like, just don't read those. And he was really sucked into it. And he said, well, I have all these symptoms. And I said, well, yeah. I know the arm thing and the neck. And he said, no. He said, I have all these cardiac symptoms.
我特意把它们藏在几本书下面，因为不想让家里任何人担心。我去厨房微波了爆米花。回来时，我爸正在读它们。我试图拿走。我说：“别读这些。”他已经完全沉浸进去了。他说：“好吧，我有所有这些症状。”我说：“嗯，是的。我知道手臂和脖子的问题。”他说：“不，我有所有这些心脏症状。”
He had always thought the stiffness in his muscles and heart troubles were unrelated.
他一直以为自己肌肉僵硬和心脏问题是无关的。
He said, well, the doctors told me I had a virus, not to worry about it. We both just looked to each other, and I said, it's not a virus. We have Emery-Dreifuss.
他说，医生告诉我这是病毒引起的，不用担心。我们俩面面相觑，我说：“不是病毒。我们得了埃默里-德雷福斯病。”
They went to the Iowa Heart Center, where doctors put a heart monitor on Jill's father. His pulse rate dropped below 30 beats per minute, which meant he was either about to win the Tour de France, or he was about to drop dead. He had a pacemaker put in immediately.
他们去了爱荷华心脏中心，医生给吉尔父亲戴上了心电监测仪。他的脉搏降到了每分钟30次以下，这意味着他要么正要赢得环法自行车赛，要么马上要猝死。他立即装上了起搏器。
She saved her dad's life. I mean, just absolutely amazing.
她救了她父亲的命。我觉得，绝对太神奇了。
This is Jill's mom, Mary.
这是吉尔的母亲，玛丽。
If it wasn't for her, how would we have ever known this? I remember being in the hospital that day. And I think he was just in awe of Jill and just love, total love for Jill. But I think it was a hard burden for her, because it just seemed like no one else was looking.
如果不是她，我们怎么会知道？记得那天在医院。我想他只是对吉尔心存敬畏，充满爱，对吉尔完全的爱。但我觉得这对她来说是个沉重的负担，因为似乎没人去关注这一切。
The Iowa Heart Center wasn't set up to confirm whether or not her family had Emery-Dreifuss. That wasn't their specialty. So she went looking for someone who could. Remember, she was 19.
爱荷华心脏中心并没有设备来确认她的家人是否患有埃默里-德雷福斯症。那不是他们的专长。所以她去寻找能做的人。记住，当时她才19岁。
Well, I went to a neurology clinic. I can remember even what I wore that day. I dressed up as professional as I could. I wanted to be taken seriously. I mean, I had on a navy pantsuit, and tried to present the articles to my neurologist.
嗯，我去了神经科门诊。我甚至记得那天穿了什么。我穿得尽可能专业。我想被认真对待。我穿了一套深蓝色裤装，试图把文章展示给我的神经科医生看。
And how did you even start that conversation? How'd you make your case?
你是怎么开启那个对话的？你是怎么阐述你的主张的？
I just said I had been studying genetics. I've been spending a great deal of time in the library, and I've come across these photos. And I am sure this is what we have, and this is the name. And could you look at these with me? And the doctor just was very abrupt with me and said, no, you don't have that, and refused to look at the papers.
我只是说我一直在研究遗传学。我花了很多时间在图书馆，我读到了这些照片。我敢肯定这就是我们的病，这是病名。你能和我一起看看吗？医生对我非常粗暴，他说：“不，你们没有这种病。”并拒绝看资料。
It might seem rude that a doctor would refuse even to look, but at the time, most doctors believed Emery-Dreifuss only occurred in men. Also, this was a self-diagnosis coming from a teenager-- a defiant teenager.
医生拒绝查看可能看起来很无礼，但当时大多数医生认为埃默里-德雷福斯症只会发生在男性身上。而且，这是一个十几岁的女孩——一个反叛的少年——做出的自我诊断。
There was times that, when I was in the doctor's office, I would see my chart, and it would just list, diagnosis muscular dystrophy, unknown etiology. I hated seeing that. I'd literally just take a pen out of my purse and I'd scratch it out and I'd write, Emery-Dreifuss muscular dystrophy. And my mom would see me do that. And she's like, you can't change your chart! I want it listed what I have.
有几次，在医生办公室，我看到我的病历，上面只是列着：“诊断：肌营养不良，病因不明”。看到那个我很难受。我会直接从包里掏出笔划掉，然后写上：“埃默里-德雷福斯肌营养不良症”。我妈看到我这么做，她说：“你不能更改病历！”我想要标明我到底得的是什么病。
In a reading binge, Jill had come across a group of researchers working out of Italy. They were looking for families with Emery-Dreifuss to study, hoping to locate the gene that causes the disease. Jill decided to write to them. She mapped out a family tree, noting the symptoms she saw in her father, two younger brothers, and a younger sister. Then she stripped down to her underwear.
在一次阅读狂潮中，吉尔接触到了一群在意大利工作的研究人员。他们正在寻找患有埃默里-德雷福斯的家庭进行研究，希望能定位致病基因。吉尔决定写信给他们。她绘制了一张家谱，记录了她在父亲、两个弟弟和一个妹妹身上观察到的症状。然后她脱光了衣服。
And then I set the timer on my camera and I took pictures of myself, because I thought, well, if that's how I identified it, let me send a picture. And just inquired, would you want to take a look at our family?
然后我设置了相机定时器，给自己拍了照，因为心想，既然我是这样鉴定出来的，不如就发张照片。然后询问他们是否想调查我们的家庭。
Up to this point, the Italians had only collected four other families to study, so they were thrilled to hear from Jill and they immediately wrote back. From the letter, it seems like they think she's a scientist who has access to a lab. They asked, can you send us DNA? If you cannot prepare DNA, just send fresh blood.
到目前为止，意大利人只收集了其他四个家庭进行研究，所以他们很激动能收到吉尔的来信。从信中看来，他们以为她是一个有实验室背景的科学家。他们问：“你能寄给我们DNA吗？如果你无法提取DNA，就寄新鲜血液。”
But 19-year-old Jill soon learned you can't just go to the local hospital and say draw my blood. I want to send it to Europe. So Jill convinced a nurse friend to smuggle needles and test tubes to her house. They filled them up with samples of her family's blood and shipped them off to Italy.
但19岁的吉尔很快意识到，你不能走进当地医院说：“抽我的血。我想寄到欧洲。”所以吉尔说服了一位护士朋友把针头和试管偷运到她家。他们装满了家人的血液样本并运往意大利。
Today, you can sequence an entire genome in a few days. But back in the mid-1990s, not so much. It was four years before Jill heard something definitive back from the Italians. They confirmed she had Emery-Dreifuss. She'd been right all these years, despite everyone telling her otherwise.
今天，你可以在几天内完成全基因组测序。但在90年代中期，可没那么容易。四年后，吉尔才从意大利人那里收到确切的消息。他们证实她确实患有埃默里-德雷福斯症。这么多年来，尽管所有人都说她错了，但她是对的。
One day, I opened email, and there it was. And that was a weird feeling to realize, OK, this is it. And I clicked on it, and they told me the name of the gene. It was nuclear lamin.
有一天，我打开邮件，结果就在那儿。意识到“好的，就是这个”，那种感觉很奇怪。我点击进去，他们告诉了我基因的名字。那是核纤层蛋白（nuclear lamin）。
The researchers had discovered the genetic cause of Jill's illness, a gene called the lamin gene. What makes the lamin gene really important is that it affects the command center inside every cell in your body. This turns other genes on and off like light switches, changing the way they build fat and muscle.
研究人员发现了导致吉尔疾病的遗传原因，一个叫做纤层蛋白基因。让纤层蛋白基因变得真正重要的是，它影响着你体内每个细胞内部的指挥中心。这就像开关一样开启或关闭其他基因，改变它们构建脂肪和肌肉的方式。
Jill's lamin gene has a typo in it, a serious one. Along the spiraling ladders of her DNA-- the 3 billion Gs, Ts, As, and Cs that make up Jill's genome-- she had one letter in the wrong place.
吉尔的纤层蛋白基因里有一个错别字，一个严重的错别字。沿着她DNA的螺旋阶梯——构成吉尔基因组的30亿个G、T、A和C——有一个字母位置放错了。
And it's just almost darkly comical to think, seriously? In this quest to find, OK, well, what happened exactly, it comes down to a G was changed to a C.
想到这个，几乎有一种黑暗的幽默感：真的吗？为了寻找答案，仅仅因为一个G变成了C？
Soon after, Jill got an internship in a lab at Johns Hopkins that was mapping diseases associated with the lamin gene . The lab director had heard about Jill's research on herself and saw a chance to have not only a dogged intern in the lab, but also their very own real-life lamin mutant.
不久后，吉尔在约翰霍普金斯大学的一个实验室获得了一份实习工作，该实验室正在绘制与纤层蛋白基因相关的疾病图谱。实验室主任听说过吉尔对自己的研究，看到了机会，不仅能得到一名执着的实习生，还能得到他们自己的真实生活中的纤层蛋白突变体。
Jill's job was to sift through scientific journals and find any references that had been linked to a lamin mutation. Sitting there day after day reading, she came across an incredibly rare disease, a disorder called partial lipodystrophy. It causes the arms and legs to look as if all the fat on them has been melted away, leaving veins and muscle to stand out.
吉尔的工作是筛选科学期刊，查找所有与纤层蛋白突变相关的引用。日复一日地坐在那里阅读，她遇到了一种极其罕见的疾病，一种叫做“部分脂肪营养不良症”的障碍。它导致手臂和腿部的脂肪仿佛被融化消失了，只剩下血管和肌肉凸显出来。
Looking at photos of patients with the disease, all Jill could think was that these people looked like her family members. Could Jill and her family have not just one, but two rare genetic diseases? The odds of getting one of them was one in a million. The odds of getting the other is one in at least a million. And the odds of getting both together? There haven't been enough human beings in the history of our species that anyone should ever get both.
看着该病患者的照片，吉尔能想到的就是这些人看起来就像她的家人们。吉尔和她的家人会不会患有两种而不是一种罕见的遗传病？得其中一种的几率是百万分之一。另一种也是百万分之一。那两者同时患上的几率呢？人类历史上还没出现过足够多的人口，让人应该得这两种病。
So just like before, when Jill discovered Emery-Dreifuss, she zeroed in on a photo in a medical article and saw herself in it. And just like before, she tried to get confirmation from doctors. She tried to tell scientists that she had the second rare disorder, partial lipodystrophy. And just like before, they said no. They said that statistically there was very little chance that could be true. Instead, they diagnosed her with something a little more common.
所以就像之前发现埃默里-德雷福斯症时一样，她盯着医学文章里的一张照片，看到了自己。就像之前一样，她试图从医生那里得到确认。她试图告诉科学家她患有第二种罕见疾病——部分脂肪营养不良症。就像之前一样，他们说不。他们说在统计学上这几乎不可能。相反，他们诊断她患上了一种更常见的病。
They didn't necessarily laugh at me but were kind of incredulous that, no, you don't have that. And they even kind of described it as intern syndrome, where you have a medical student that's being introduced to a lot of new diseases and they keep thinking they have what they're reading about.
他们不一定嘲笑我，但确实很怀疑：“不，你没得那种病。”他们甚至把这描述为“实习生综合症”，即一个医学实习生接触到很多新疾病，就不断认为自己得了自己正在读的那种。
I just thought, well, I must be wrong. I think I, too, was buying into that idea that that's quite a reach to think that you have the second genetic disorder, because it's so rare, too. I just kind of thought, well, maybe I am nuts. So I kind of backed away from that, even though it was kind of a deja vu feeling.
我只是想，好吧，我一定错了。我想我当时也信了那个念头，认为觉得身患第二种遗传病太扯了，因为它太罕见了。所以我退缩了，尽管那是一种似曾相识的感觉。
So she dropped it. She stopped reading about this new disease. And before long, she stopped doing research into Emery-Dreifuss, too, mostly because the research she was doing started to freak her out. In the case studies she read, the average person with Emery-Dreifuss was dead by their early 40s. She was 25, and anxiety over this was landing her in the hospital.
于是她放弃了。她停止了关于这种新病的阅读。没过多久，她也停止了对埃默里-德雷福斯症的研究，主要是因为她所做的研究开始让她感到恐惧。在她读到的病例研究中，埃默里-德雷福斯患者平均在40岁出头就会死亡。她25岁，对此的焦虑让她住进了医院。
I had two panic attacks that were brought on by the stress of reading all of these things-- that they just died suddenly. And I went to a counselor for a while. I worked with my cardiologist. And we decided it was just too much information. It wasn't healthy. So I really just didn't look up things, didn't read articles. And I really got to the point that I decided I want to go on with my old life.
我因为读这些东西带来的压力而发作过两次恐慌症——关于他们突然死亡。我咨询了一段时间的心理医生。我与我的心脏病专家合作。我们决定信息量太大了。这不健康。所以我真的没再去查，没再读文章。我真的到了决定要继续过我原来生活的那一步。
So she went cold turkey. No more medical research, no more DIY diagnosis. She took a job as a writing instructor at local community colleges, and taught adult education classes at night. She started dating, eventually meeting the man who would become her husband. And even though there was a 50/50 chance that she would pass on the Emery-Dreifuss gene mutation, they decided to have a child.
所以她彻底停了。不再有医学研究，不再有DIY诊断。她在当地社区学院找了一份写作讲师的工作，晚上教成人教育课程。她开始约会，最终遇到了后来成为她丈夫的男人。尽管她有50%的几率将埃默里-德雷福斯基因突变遗传下去，但他们决定要一个孩子。
Her pregnancy was normal, and her baby, Martin, doesn't have the disease. But after he was born, Jill really deteriorated physically. If you've ever had a muscle twitch, you know how strange it feels to not have control of your body. Jill's muscles started twitching from head to toe, sometimes for hours at a time, and she was suddenly having to hold onto her husband to steady herself.
她的怀孕过程很正常，她的宝宝马丁没有遗传这种病。但在他出生后，吉尔的身体状况确实恶化了。如果你曾经有过肌肉抽搐，你就知道身体不受控制的感觉有多奇怪。吉尔的肌肉开始从头到脚抽搐，有时一抽就是几个小时，她突然不得不抓住丈夫来保持平衡。
The best way I can describe what it was like, it would be like where gravity is getting incredibly heavy and someone turns up the knob. And you think of how high would they have to turn up this gravity that I can't get up off the floor by myself, I can't stand upright, I can't take a step? You know, it's a tremendous amount of force pushing on the body.
关于那种感觉，我能描述的最好方式是：就像重力变得极其沉重，有人把重力旋钮调大了。你会想，他们得把重力调到多高，我才能没法独自从地板上起来，没法站直，没法迈步？你知道，那是巨大的压力作用在身体上。
By Martin's first birthday, she could barely walk.
在马丁一岁生日时，她几乎无法走路了。
One day, he was calling that he wanted macaroni and cheese. And I knew-- I had like six steps to take. And I realized, this is it. This is the last six steps I'm going to take. I just knew I was at that point that I was going to not be able to get up again.
有一天，他在喊要吃通心粉奶酪。我意识到——我大概还有六步路要走。我意识到，就是现在了。这是我最后能走的六步。我只是知道自己到了那个点，我再也没法站起来了。
At the same time, Jill's father was also losing his ability to walk. So father and daughter transitioned to life in motorized scooters. Jill says her dad was discouraged for the first time in his life. After a visit with a neurologist, he told her, I feel like I go there just to be weighed. Then one day, she got a call from her mom, and it was about Dad.
与此同时，吉尔的父亲也正在失去走路的能力。于是父女俩的生活过渡到了电动代步车。吉尔说她爸爸一生中第一次感到气馁。在一次神经科医生复诊后，他告诉她：“我觉得我来这里只是为了被称重。”然后有一天，她接到妈妈的电话，是关于爸爸的。
He just moved from his scooter into his favorite chair. He said to my mom he just felt tired, and then he'd simply just bowed his head and he didn't breathe again and he died. He had a sudden cardiac death.
他刚从滑板车移到他最喜欢的椅子上。他跟我妈说他只是觉得累，然后他只是低下了头，就没再呼吸，去世了。他发生了心源性猝死。
At what age was that?
那是多少岁？
He was 63.
他63岁。
On the day he passed away, Jill and her siblings and relatives gathered at her parents' house.
在他去世那天，吉尔和兄弟姐妹以及亲戚们聚集在她父母家。
After most of the people had gone, it was kind of slowing down. And my sister said, I got this to show you. She starts pulling up pictures of this extremely muscular athlete. And I just took one look at it and just kind of went, we don't-- what? We don't have that. I mean, what are you talking about?
大部分人走后，气氛平静下来。我姐姐说：“我有这个给你看。”她开始展示这个极其强壮的运动员的照片。我只看了一眼，就说：“我们没有……什么？我们没有那个。你在说什么？”
This, of course, was Priscilla. At first, Jill didn't get it, didn't see any connection with the musclebound athlete. It had been 12 years since she went cold turkey on medical research.
当然，这就是普里西拉。起初，吉尔没明白，没看出这个肌肉发达的运动员有什么联系。距离她“戒掉”医学研究已经过去12年了。
But a week later, Jill got curious. She started googling pictures of Priscilla-- not just running photos, but shots of her at home doing regular things, like feeding her daughter baby food.
但一周后，吉尔产生了好奇。她开始谷歌普里西拉的照片——不仅是跑步照，还有她在家里做日常琐事的镜头，比如喂女儿吃婴儿食品。
It helped seeing the clothing on her to see how it fit. It was just unmistakable. It's like a computer that could analyze a photograph and get a match, and be 100% sure that's the same shoulder. That's the same upper arm. I see the same veins. I see them branching this way. You just know. And that's hard to convey. How could you just know? But I knew we were very likely cut from the same cloth-- a very, very, very rare cloth.
看到她身上的衣服怎么穿才看得出来。那是不言而喻的。就像一台可以分析照片并进行匹配的计算机，能够百分之百确定那是同一个肩膀。那是同一个上臂。我看到了同样的血管。我看到它们以这种方式分支。你就是知道。这很难传达。怎么可能一眼就知道？但我知道我们很可能出自同一种布料——一种非常非常稀有的布料。
It was the third time Jill saw something in a photo other people didn't see. It had happened with Emery-Dreifuss. It happened with lipodystrophy. Now she saw that she and Priscilla were both missing fat in the same places on their arms and legs. They had the exact same muscle divisions in the exact same places in the hips and butt. Jill was certain this was because they shared a mutant gene. And the only question was, why did the gene blow up Priscilla with muscles and take Jill's away?
这是吉尔第三次看到别人看不到的照片细节。埃默里-德雷福斯症是这样，脂肪营养不良症也是这样。现在她看到她和普里西拉都在手臂和腿上的相同部位缺失脂肪。她们在臀部和胯部的相同位置有完全相同的肌肉分块。吉尔确信这是因为她们共享一个突变基因。唯一的问题是：为什么同一个基因在普里西拉身上膨胀出肌肉，却从吉尔身上夺走了肌肉？
This is my kryptonite, but it's her rocket fuel. I mean, we're like comic book superheroes that are just as divergent as could be. I mean, her body has found a way around it somehow.
这是我的氪星石，但却是她的火箭燃料。我的意思是，我们就像漫画书里的超级英雄，虽然截然不同。我的意思是，她的身体以某种方式找到了应对方法。
I know that sounds like the plot of a Hollywood movie. In fact, it's totally the plot of Unbreakable, The Bruce Willis, Samuel L Jackson film. Jackson plays a broken-boned, physically fragile man searching for his genetic opposite, a man born so strong his body will survive any physical trauma. In the final scene, Jackson tells Willis that he's the guy.
我知道这听起来像好莱坞电影的情节。事实上，这完全是《不死劫》的剧情，那部布鲁斯·威利斯和塞缪尔·杰克逊的电影。杰克逊扮演一个骨骼脆弱、身体虚弱的男人，寻找他的基因对立面——一个天生强壮、身体能幸存于任何物理创伤的男人。在最后一场戏中，杰克逊告诉威利斯，他就是那个人。
(SUBJECT) SAMUEL L JACKSON: It all makes sense. In a comic, you know how you can tell who the arch-villain's going to be? He's the exact opposite of the hero.
（塞缪尔·杰克逊）这一切都说得通。在漫画里，你知道怎么辨别谁会是终极大反派吗？他就是英雄的完全对立面。
So Jill wanted to enlist Priscilla in her genetic detective work, but there was a practical problem. She had no idea how to go about reaching her.
所以吉尔想拉拢普里西拉进行她的基因侦探工作，但有一个实际问题。她根本不知道怎么联系她。
I mean, I had crazy ideas, like can I fly to Canada and show up at a meet in Greece and try to talk to her? And if you're on this motorized scooter, it's like, you're just going into end up with a restraining order at best. I mean, people will think you're crazy. I was just trying to resign myself to the fact that, well, what am I going to do?
我的意思是，我有一些疯狂的想法，比如我能飞到加拿大或者出现在希腊的一场比赛中试图和她交谈吗？如果你坐着这辆电动车，那结果充其量是收到限制令。我的意思是，人们会觉得你疯了。我只是试着接受现实，好吧，我能做什么呢？
A full year passed. And then Jill happened to be in earshot of her television when I started yammering about athletes and genetics on Good Morning America.
整整一年过去了。然后吉尔恰好在电视播放时听到了我的声音，当时我正在《早安美国》上滔滔不绝谈论运动员和基因。
Find the best fit for your unique genome, and then specialize in the--
找到最适合你独特基因组的，然后专攻……
And I thought, oh, this is just divine providence. This is exactly what I'm looking for.
我觉得：噢，这就是神圣的天意。这正是我在寻找的。
Jill reached out to me with her request, and I did happen to have a way to get it to Priscilla-- through her agent.
吉尔带着她的请求联系了我，我确实有办法把它传达给普里西拉——通过她的经纪人。
It was such an odd request. It's just really out there, right?
这是一个非常奇怪的请求。这真的很离谱，对吧？
This, of course, is Priscilla.
当然，这就是普里西拉。
He was just like, this lady, she's in Iowa. She says she has the same gene as you and wants to have a conversation. I was kind of like, oh, I don't know, Kris. And he's just, have a conversation. See where it goes.
他只是说：“这位女士，她在爱荷华州。她说她有和你一样的基因，想谈谈。”我当时心想：哦，我不知道，克里斯。他只是说：“聊聊吧。看看会发生什么。”
Jill sent Priscilla the same bound packet that she sent me. And it wasn't any of the cryptic science that got to Priscilla. It was the childhood stories Jill shared about kids pointing at the veins in her legs. Priscilla said she always used to come home sad and crying. She'd ask her parents--
吉尔给普里西拉发了同样的装订册，发给我那本。并没有什么晦涩的科学让普里西拉动容。是吉尔分享的孩子时的故事，关于孩子们指着她腿上的静脉嘲笑。普里西拉说她总是伤心地哭着回家。她问她的父母——
Can I get the veins removed from my legs, because the boys are making fun of me? It was just like, ew, your legs are veiny. Ew, why does it look like that?
“我能把腿上的静脉去掉吗？因为男孩子们在嘲笑我。”就像：“噢，你的腿太难看了。噢，为什么看起来是那样？”
Once she grew up, the finger-pointing didn't end. It just morphed. When people see huge, shredded muscles like Priscilla's on an athlete, it usually means one thing-- steroids. And Priscilla's been dogged by doping rumors since college. After she won the Olympic bronze medal in Beijing, some media outlets in Europe began to openly accuse her. And of course, there were the not-so-furtive glances.
长大后，指指点点并没有结束。它只是变了形。当人们在运动员身上看到像普里西拉那样巨大、线条分明的肌肉时，通常意味着一件事——类固醇。而普里西拉从大学起就一直受到兴奋剂谣言的困扰。她在北京赢得奥运铜牌后，欧洲的一些媒体开始公开指责她。当然，还有那些并不那么隐秘的窥视。
You'd walk by and people kind of like would whisper, like, oh, look at her glutes, or look at her arms or her shoulders or her calves. And just like, ooh, look, look, look. It's more like on the intern-- I remember there was one picture that was put up. They put a big dude's face on my body and he was just like, [GROWLING], like, I'm lifting-- because I'm running and pushing towards the finish line, so I'm using every ounce, every inch, every piece of energy in my body to get to that finish line.
你走过去，人们会低语，比如：“噢，看她的臀部，或者看她的手臂、肩膀或小腿。”就好像：“噢，看，看，看。”更多是在网上——我记得有一张照片被挂了出来。他们把一个大块头男人的脸贴在我的身体上，他就像在——（低吼）——因为我正在跑步冲刺终点线，所以我用尽了全身每一盎司、每一英寸、每一片能量来抵达终点。
That was pretty messed up. And I was really pissed about that. And I got tested. I felt like I was targeted, because I got tested so much for track and field. And I think a lot of people really, honestly, truly believed that I was taking steroids.
那真的很过分。我对此非常生气。我接受了检测。我觉得我被盯上了，因为我接受了太多田径检测。我想很多人真的、老实说、真的相信我服用了类固醇。
At the world championships in Berlin in 2009, Priscilla was drug-tested just minutes before winning a silver medal. There's not even supposed to be any drug testing that close to the race. Then the following month, at a meet-and-greet, someone stole her training journal out of her bag. It was at the very bottom, underneath expensive workout clothes and shoes, none of which were taken. Why steal a training journal? As someone who's covered a lot of doping stories, I'm convinced someone thought the journal contained her steroid regimen.
在2009年柏林世锦赛上，普里西拉在赢得银牌前几分钟接受了药检。那甚至不应该在比赛前这么近的时间进行药检。随后的一个月，在一次见面会上，有人从她的包里偷走了她的训练日志。那是在最底层，在昂贵的运动服和鞋子下面，而那些昂贵的东西都没被拿走。为什么要偷一本训练日志？作为报道过很多兴奋剂报道的人，我确信有人认为日志里包含她的类固醇方案。
Priscilla and Jill spent a lot of time talking on the phone. And eight months after I first put them in touch, they finally met in person in Toronto, where Priscilla lived. They picked a hotel lobby. Jill arrived first.
普里西拉和吉尔花了很多时间通电话。在我第一次让她们联系上八个月后，她们终于在普里西拉居住的多伦多见了面。她们选了一个酒店大堂。吉尔先到了。
So it got to be a few minutes past the time we were going to meet, and then a couple more minutes. And I started to get really scared, because I'm like, I have so much riding on this. I was just watching the doors like, OK, is this her? Is this her? I wasn't sure. And I see this lady that, oh, my gosh, this is like seeing family.
过了约定时间几分钟，然后又过了几分钟。我开始感到非常害怕，因为我想：我把赌注全压在这上面了。我只是盯着门口心想：好了，是她吗？是她吗？我不确定。然后我看到了那位女士，天哪，这就像见到家人。
Priscilla felt the same way.
普里西拉也有同样的感觉。
It really was just like a wow moment-- like "do I know you?" kind of thing. So then we started talking, just giggling about it, like, OK, I'm going to flex for you. And then it's a little harder for her to get her sweater off, so she's pulling her sweater off to show me. She's like, see? I do have the definition, too. I'm like, you do. You do. But she's like, but it's a lot smaller than yours. And then we'd kind of giggle.
这真的就是一个“哇”的时刻——就像“我认识你吗？”那种感觉。然后我们开始交谈，对此咯咯直笑，就像：“好吧，我要为你展示一下。”然后她脱毛衣有点困难，所以她脱掉毛衣让我看。她说：“看到了吗？我也确实有线条。”我说：“确实。你有。但比你的小得多。”然后我们就咯咯笑起来。
But it was still like, OK, there's something real. There's something here. Let's research and let's find out because how could the gene do this to you and do this to me? That was where my question was. I'm like, how?
但那仍然感觉像：“好吧，有真实的东西存在。这里有什么东西。让我们研究研究，找出真相，因为基因怎么会这样对你又这样对我？”这就是我的问题。我说：“怎么会？”
It took a year to find a doctor to test Priscilla. Finally, Jill went to a medical conference and approached the foremost expert in lipodystrophy, Dr. Abhimanyu Garg, who runs a lab at University of Texas Southwestern Medical Center. He agreed to do the testing.
花了一年时间才找到一名医生测试普里西拉。最后，吉尔参加了一个医学会议，接触了脂肪营养不良症领域的顶级专家——阿比曼纽·加格博士，他在德克萨斯大学西南医学中心经营一个实验室。他同意进行检测。
The results showed that Jill had been right. She and Priscilla do have a genetic connection. They each have a single typo on the same one of our 23,000 genes, the lamin gene. It's not the exact same typo, but they're almost right next to each other. That splinter of distance and typo location makes the difference between Jill's muscles and Priscilla's muscles. It's why Jill has Emery-Dreifuss and Priscilla doesn't.
结果显示吉尔是对的。她和普里西拉确实有基因联系。她们每个人都在我们的23,000个基因中，在同一个纤层蛋白基因上有一个错别字。虽然不是同一个错别字，但它们的位置几乎紧挨着。那一点点的距离和错别字位置的差异造成了吉尔肌肉和普里西拉肌肉的区别。这就是为什么吉尔患有埃默里-德雷福斯症而普里西拉没有。
But Dr. Garg also found that they do share a disease. They both have the exact same rare subtype of lipodystrophy, the disease that wastes away fat. Jill had been told it had nothing to do with her back when she was a summer intern at Johns Hopkins. Jill had been right about that all along. Dr. Garg called Priscilla immediately to give her the news. He caught her at the mall shopping with her kids.
但加格博士也发现她们确实患有同一种病。她们俩都患有同一种罕见的脂肪营养不良亚型，即消耗脂肪的疾病。吉尔早在约翰霍普金斯大学做暑期实习时就被告知这与她无关。吉尔一直以来都是对的。加格博士立即打电话给普里西拉告诉她这个消息。当时她正在商场里和孩子们购物。
I was just dreaming about going and getting a big juicy burger and fries. And Dr. Garg calls me and says, I have your results. I'm like, OK. And then I was like, can I call you back, because I'm in the mall right now? He goes, um, no, it's kind of important. Are you about to go eat lunch? And I was like, yes. He's like, you're only allowed to have salad. You're on track for a pancreatitis attack. And I was like, say what?
我当时正梦想着去吃个大汁多肉的汉堡和薯条。加格博士打来电话说：“我有你的检查结果了。”我说：“好吧。”然后我说：“能晚点回给你吗？因为我正在商场。”他说：“嗯，不行，这很重要。你准备去吃午饭吗？”我说：“是的。”他说：“你只准吃沙拉。你有患胰腺炎的风险。”我说：“你说什么？”
Then he told Priscilla that, despite her rigorous training regimen, her untreated lipodystrophy left her with 15 times the normal amount of fat in her blood. Her next hamburger could land her in the emergency room. She was that close.
然后他告诉普里西拉，尽管她训练极其严苛，但未经治疗的脂肪营养不良症导致她血液中的脂肪含量是正常水平的15倍。她的下一个汉堡就可能让她住进急诊室。她离那步已经很近了。
In other words, once again, Jill steered someone away from a medical disaster. She'd saved her dad's life. Now, using the cutting-edge medical tool known as Google Images, she caused the most intense medical intervention in the life of this professional athlete.
换句话说，吉尔再次引导某人远离了医疗灾难。她救了她父亲的命。现在，利用名为“谷歌图片搜索”的尖端医疗工具，她对这位职业运动员的生活进行了最剧烈的医学干预。
That's when I was just like, oh, my gosh. If this wasn't for Jill, I would definitely have been in the hospital. And I called her and I told her. I was like, you pretty much just saved me from having to go to the hospital. And she goes, what? I go, Dr. Garg told me that I have the gene and my numbers are out of the roof.
那是我当时的想法：天哪。如果不是吉尔，我绝对会住进医院。我打电话告诉她。我说：“你简直救了我，让我不用去医院。”她说：“什么？”我说：“加格博士告诉我我携带那个基因，我的指标简直爆表了。”
Scientists can learn all sorts of things by studying very rare genetic diseases. For instance, research on a rare gene mutation that gives people freakishly low cholesterol levels led to a drug that treats high cholesterol. An Alzheimer's treatment might come from studying a small group of people in Iceland. They have a super-rare mutation that protects their brains.
科学家通过研究非常罕见的遗传病可以学到各种东西。例如，对一种赋予人们极低胆固醇水平的罕见基因突变的研究，促成了一种治疗高胆固醇的药物。阿尔茨海默病的治疗方法可能来自研究冰岛的一小群人。他们有一种超级罕见的突变保护着大脑。
Recently, a group of scientists started something called the Matchmaker Exchange. It's a kind of OkCupid for rare diseases, where people can share genetic and symptom information with each other and doctors. The hope is that it will spark new discoveries.
最近，一群科学家启动了一个叫做“媒人交换”的项目。这是一种罕见病的OkCupid，人们可以分享基因和症状信息。希望它能激发新的发现。
It's just the willpower of Jill that have made things possible.
正是吉尔的意志力让这一切成为可能。
That's Etienne Lefai, a molecular biologist in France. He does super-technical work on a protein with the lovely name SREBP-1. It affects fat storage. And his research team showed that messing around with it can create mice with almost no muscle at all, or potentially little rodent Schwarzeneggers. When Jill first reached him, she told him that he may have found the actual biological mechanism that makes her and Priscilla so different.
那是法国分子生物学家艾蒂安·勒费。他在做一项关于一种拥有可爱名字“SREBP-1”蛋白质的超技术工作。它影响脂肪储存。他的研究小组表明，搞乱它会导致产生几乎没有肌肉的老鼠，或者潜在的小型啮齿类施瓦辛格。当吉尔第一次联系他时，她告诉他，他可能找到了使她和普里西拉如此不同的实际生物机制。
OK, that triggers a kind of reflection from my side, saying, that's a really good question. That's a really, really good question, because I have no idea of what I can do with genetic diseases before she contacted me. Now I have changed the path of my team, research object. And this is only because Jill contacted me two years ago. She's totally awesome.
好吧，这触发了我这边的反思，心想：那是一个非常好的问题。那是一个非常、非常好的一系列问题，因为在她联系我之前，我根本不知道我对遗传病能做什么。现在我改变了我团队的研究方向。这仅仅是因为吉尔两年前联系了我。她简直太棒了。
And have you ever had the experience of someone outside the scientific community affecting your research agenda in this kind of way?
你有没有过科学界之外的人以这种方式影响你的研究议程的经历？
In my life, no. People from outside coming and giving me hopes, new ideas-- I have no other example of these kind of things. You know, maybe it happens once in a scientific life.
在我的一生中，没有。来自外部的人给我希望、新点子——我没有其他这种事情的例子了。你知道，也许在科研生涯中一生只会发生一次。
Of course, this is so different than the skepticism Jill's gotten from scientists and doctors for decades. I checked back in with one of the doubters, Robert Green-- you know, the geneticist at Harvard I first talked to who was so incredulous about any genetic connection between Jill and Priscilla. I email him the results of Priscilla's genetic test.
当然，这与吉尔几十年来从科学家和医生那里得到的怀疑截然不同。我回访了其中一位怀疑者罗伯特·格林——就是我最先采访的那位哈佛遗传学家，他对吉尔和普里西拉之间的任何基因联系都极度怀疑。我给他发了普里西拉的基因检测结果。
Oh, I was knocked over. I was completely and utterly astounded. And I remember thinking I was ashamed that I had doubted this individual because she turned out to have a remarkable discovery.
噢，我被击倒了。我完全且彻底地震惊了。我记得我感到很羞愧，因为我怀疑了这个个体，因为她竟然作出了一个非凡的发现。
About a week after I talked to Doctors Green and Lefai, I played those conversations back for Jill
在我采访格林博士和勒费博士的一周后，我把这些对话放给了吉尔听。
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
Could you hear that OK?
你能听清吗？
Yeah, I could hear that.
对，我可以听到。
So what's in your mind when you hear that?
当你听到这些时，你在想什么？
It really does feel really good. Wow. It's kind of like this weight come off of me. So I'm exhausted emotionally and intellectually, and in every way possible. I am so happy. I don't want to be the crazy person that's on the internet all the time coming in. I really feel confident we can go somewhere with this. And I've got some really great people.
感觉真的非常好。哇。就像这种重负从我身上卸下来了。所以我现在在情感上和智力上都精疲力竭，在各种可能的方式上。我太高兴了。我不想成为那个总是在网上出现的那种疯子。我非常有信心我们能以此取得进展。我有几个非常棒的人帮我。
Jill says she's proved her point. She says she's retiring from DIY medical research. She gave me the same line that professional athletes use. "I want to spend more time with my family." But her mother doesn't believe she's retiring, nor does Dr. Lefai. And I certainly don't believe her.
吉尔说她已经证明了自己的观点。她说她要从DIY医学研究中退休。她对我说了职业运动员常用的那句台词：“我想花更多时间陪陪家人。”但她妈妈不相信她会退休，勒费博士也不信。我也绝对不信她。
Recently, Jill sent me an email. She picked up on a tidbit in a very technical scientific paper about potentially reversing muscular dystrophy. "I don't want to read too much into this," she wrote me, "but, of course, I'm curious."
最近，吉尔给我发了一封邮件。她在非常技术性的科学论文中捕捉到一个关于潜在逆转肌营养不良症的细微片段。“我不想过度解读这个，”她写道，“但，当然，我很好奇。”
David Epstein. The book that he wrote that kicked all this off is The Sports Gene-- Inside the Science of Extraordinary Athletic Performance. He has more about Jill and Priscilla, including jaw-dropping photos, at propublica.org.
大卫·爱泼斯坦。他写的开启这一切的那本书叫《运动基因——非凡运动表现背后的科学》。他在propublica.org上有关于吉尔和普里西拉的更多内容，包括令人惊掉下巴的照片。
In the years since we first ran this story, as predicted, Jill has gone back to the research game. She still talks to Priscilla, who recently retired from track and field.
自从我们第一次播出这个故事以来的几年里，正如预料的那样，吉尔又回到了研究赛道上。她仍然和普里西拉保持联系，后者最近已从田径界退役。
Coming up. OK, you know how we started today's program with the color green that was not green? After the break, Tig Notaro finds a joke that is also not a joke. That's from WBEZ Chicago when our program continues.
接下来的节目。好了，你知道我们今天节目开头讲的那个“绿色的非绿色”吗？广告之后，蒂格·诺塔罗会讲一个同样“不是笑话”的笑话。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，我们的节目继续。
[ANNOUNCEMENT]
[公告]
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Something Only I Can See." We have stories of people who spot something that no one else has noticed and then feel compelled to tell somebody, show somebody, do something about it.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选定一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的主题是“只有我能看到的东西”。我们讲述了一些人发现没人注意到的东西，然后感到有义务去告诉某人、展示给某人、并为此做点什么的故事。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Mom Jokes.
我们进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“妈妈笑话”。
So comedians don't usually laugh at their own jokes as a rule. It's gauche. It makes things less funny as a rule. But, as Van Halen once said, "rules are for fools." Tig Notaro has been on our program before. She talked to Nancy Updike about a recent rule-breaking addition to one of her stand-up shows.
通常来说，喜剧演员不会在自己的笑话里大笑。那样太笨拙了。那样会使事情变得不那么好笑。但是，就像范·海伦曾经说过的，“规则是为傻瓜准备的”。蒂格·诺塔罗之前来过我们的节目。她和南希·厄普代克谈论了她单口相声演出中一个打破常规的新增内容。
As we know, 58% of all important events in America start in the car. Tig and her fiancee Stephanie were driving along with--
众所周知，美国58%的重要事件都始于车里。蒂格和她的未婚妻斯蒂芬妮开车带着——
Her mother, her sister, my stepfather, and my brother. And we were in New Orleans. And--
她妈妈、她妹妹、我的继父，还有我的弟弟。我们在新奥尔良。然后——
This is a big car.
这辆车很大。
Yeah, we had an SUV. And my fiancee, her mother was telling us this joke that she had come up with. And in trying to tell the joke that she had made up, she was laughing so hard she couldn't get the joke out.
对，我们有辆SUV。我未婚妻的妈妈在给我们讲她编的一个笑话。在试图讲出她编的那个笑话时，她笑得太厉害了，话都说不出来。
This went on for a couple of minutes-- laughing, catching her breath, almost starting to tell the joke, and then more uncontrollable laughing, until everyone in the car was laughing just watching her trying to tell the joke.
这种情况持续了几分钟——大笑、喘气、差点就要讲出来，然后是更多无法控制的大笑，直到车里的每个人看着她试图讲笑话的样子都笑得前仰后合。
I don't know that I've ever written a joke this funny. This is like--
我不知道我有没有写出过这么好笑的笑话。这就像——
Right. This is my job and I have never made somebody laugh as hard as you are making your own self laugh.
没错。这是我的职业，但我从来没让人笑得像你笑自己那么厉害过。
Exactly. It's just like, come on, Carol. What is this joke?
没错。就是那样，拜托了，卡罗尔。到底是什么笑话？
And then Tig had a vision of what needed to happen at her next stand-up show.
然后蒂格脑海中出现了一个念头，觉得在她的下一场单口相声里必须发生些什么。
It became very apparent to me. I just thought, oh, my gosh, I have to have her on my show to tell her joke, whatever it is.
这对我来说变得非常明显。我想：天哪，我必须让她上台讲她的笑话，无论它是什么。
Before she got to the joke? Before she even told the joke?
在她讲出来之前？在笑话还没讲出来之前？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Just while she was laughing?
就在她大笑的时候？
Yeah. Oh, my gosh, immediately.
是的。天哪，立刻。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Oh, boy. Coming to the stage, please welcome my girlfriend's mother, Carol Ashton.
噢，天哪。请上台欢迎我女朋友的妈妈，卡罗尔·阿什顿。
[ENTRANCE MUSIC]
[入场音乐]
Two weeks after the car ride, Tig made her vision come true. Carol walks onto the stage of a comedy club in Los Angeles called Largo. She's not in jeans. She's not in comedy club casual. She is a tasteful mom in cropped white pants carrying her purse. She is a civilian.
在车程两周后，蒂格实现了她的构想。卡罗尔走上洛杉矶Largo喜剧俱乐部的舞台。她没穿牛仔裤。也没穿喜剧俱乐部的那种休闲装。她是一位优雅的妈妈，穿着白色九分裤，拎着手袋。她是一个局外人。
Yeah, how are you feeling?
是啊，你感觉怎么样？
Well, I can't really describe how I'm feeling, because I've never felt this emotion before. So I don't know what it is.
嗯，我无法描述这种感觉，因为我从未有过这种情绪。所以不知道那是什么。
You just bummed everyone out, Carol.
你让大家都冷场了，卡罗尔。
Carol knew two things about her own joke when she walked onto the stage. She knew that it was not a very good joke. She told Tig when Tig was trying to convince her to come on stage. She said, this is nuts. Nobody's going to laugh. Carol also knew that she herself could not tell the joke without laughing. She was living the mystery many of us have lived-- the all-the-way-inside joke. The joke that is funny beyond reason in your head and you cannot communicate the funniness, because you don't even understand it. That's what Carol knew. So she was nervous.
卡罗尔上台前对自己的笑话心里有数。她知道这不是个好笑话。在蒂格试图说服她上台时，她跟蒂格说过：这太疯狂了。没人会笑。卡罗尔也知道自己讲这个笑话时一定忍不住大笑。她正经历着我们许多人经历过的神秘——“彻底的内心笑话”。那种在你脑海里极其好笑、但你却无法传达笑点，因为连你自己都不明白它为什么好笑的笑话。这就是卡罗尔所知道的。所以她很紧张。
Can you tell me how and when you thought of the joke?
你能告诉我你是怎么以及什么时候想到这个笑话的吗？
OK. Well, first, I would feel a lot more comfortable--
好的。嗯，首先，我会觉得舒服得多——
If I left?
如果我离开？
No. Actually, I would feel a lot less uncomfortable if--
不。其实，如果……我会觉得不那么尴尬——
If everyone left.
如果大家都离开。
Yeah. But if you told them this was not my idea.
对。但如果你告诉他们这不是我的主意。
Oh, they know that one-- was there one person at all here tonight? Do not be shy. Raise your hand if you think Carol Ashton said, hey, Tig. It's Carol. I have got some stand-up that is going to blow your mind. Carol, I can't just put you on stage at Largo. Wait till you hear the joke, kid. Kid? Must be good.
噢，他们知道的——今晚这儿有哪怕一个人吗？别害羞。觉得是卡罗尔·阿什顿主动说：“嘿，蒂格，我是卡罗尔，我有一些能让你大脑爆炸的单口相声”的人，请举手。卡罗尔，我不能随随便便把你安排上Largo的舞台。等等，听到这个笑话再说，孩子。孩子？那肯定很好笑。
Nobody here thinks that you asked to be here. Were you driving along and the idea came to you?
这儿没人认为你是主动要求的。你是开车的时候突然想到的吗？
Yeah, I was driving alone, and I got this great idea. I thought, this is a very funny joke.
对，我当时一个人开车，想到了这个伟大的点子。我想：这是一个非常有趣的笑话。
Which is why you're here tonight, Carol.
这就是你今晚在这儿的原因，卡罗尔。
I'm here! First, I have to explain, though. It's kind of like--
我在这儿了！首先，我得解释一下。它有点像——
OK. Go ahead. Set it up.
好的。请继续。讲讲背景。
That it's like a play on words.
就像是一种文字游戏。
It's good to explain what genre the joke is. Don't let them figure it out. You tell them. Tell them, Carol.
解释笑话类型很好。别让他们自己猜。你告诉他们。告诉他们，卡罗尔。
Right. Well, Stephanie said, it's like that Lou Gehrig joke, where it's, gee, what are the odds of Lou Gehrig getting Lou Gehrig's disease? It's that kind of joke.
对。嗯，斯蒂芬妮说，它就像那个路·格里克笑话，“天哪，路·格里克得路·格里克病的几率是多少？”它是那种类型的笑话。
All right. We got the genre down.
好了。我们搞清流派了。
So I'm driving along and it came to me about-- the only problem is it's about somebody that's not really in the news-- well, never really in the news, but in the public eye anymore.
所以我当时开车，想到了这个——唯一的问题是，它关于一个新闻里不再出现的人——嗯，从来没真的出现在新闻里，但不再出现在公众视野里的人。
OK. So it is out of date?
好的。所以它过时了？
Yeah. It's out of date. That's the downside.
对。它过时了。这就是缺点。
All right. So we got the genre. We've established that this is completely out-of-date material.
好了。所以我们确定了流派，确定了这是完全过时的素材。
And so, since you're the comedian--
那么，既然你是喜剧演员——
Not right now.
我现在不是。
Of course, everything Carol is doing is usually comedy death-- explaining the joke, exposing the machinery of it-- and she is killing.
当然，卡罗尔做的一切通常都是喜剧死刑——解释笑话，拆解它的结构——但她却反响极好。
Should I say who the joke is about?
我该说说笑话的主人公是谁吗？
Well--
嗯——
That's necessary, right?
很有必要，对吧？
It's your joke. I--
这是你的笑话，我——
OK, so the joke is about Paris Hilton. See what I mean? Like, Paris Hilton's dead now. So yeah, it's about Paris Hilton. And so this is the joke. Who would name their kid--
好的，所以这个笑话是关于帕里斯·希尔顿的。看到我的意思了吗？就像，帕里斯·希尔顿现在都销声匿迹了。所以是的，它是关于帕里斯·希尔顿的。所以这就是笑话。谁会给孩子取名叫——
[LAUGHING]
[大笑]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
That is always part of the joke. She laughs at herself for two minutes.
那始终是笑话的一部分。她自嘲了两分钟。
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
Carol's rocking backward and slapping her knee, she's laughing so hard. She has spent the last 10 minutes giving caveats, laying out everything the joke has going against it, why it's no good. And then when the joke comes into her head, as she's about to tell it, none of that matters.
卡罗尔向后仰着，拍着膝盖，笑得如此厉害。她花了最后10分钟给笑话列出预防针，铺陈了它所有的劣势，为什么它不好笑。然后当笑话出现在她脑海里，就在她要讲出来时，那些都不重要了。
[LAUGHING]
[大笑]
Who would name their kid after a hotel chain?
谁会用连锁酒店的名字给孩子命名？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I know who. The same people that would name their kid after a famous city in France. I think it's so funny.
我知道是谁。就是那些用法国名城名字给孩子命名的人。我觉得这太搞笑了。
No, I--
不，我——
[LAUGHING]
[大笑]
Ladies and gentlemen, Carol Ashton.
女士们先生们，卡罗尔·阿什顿。
[HOOTING AND HOLLERING]
[欢呼声]
I mean, when I got off stage that night, I don't know if it was Flanagan, the owner of Largo, but somebody was like, I think that was the biggest response that they'd ever heard in that room. It was almost like one of the biggest comedians in the world made a guest appearance on my show.
我的意思是，那天晚上我下台时，我不知道那是Largo的老板弗拉纳根还是谁，总之有人说，我想那是那个房间里听到过的最大回响。就像世界上最伟大的喜剧演员之一在我的节目里做了一次客串演出。
All jokes start as inside jokes, inside someone's head. Some of them make it out into the world and catch on, and that's comedy, the way it usually works. This was a rare chance to root for the other kind of joke-- the nonstarter, the crush no one understands, including you. Your rational brain can make its rational arguments, and then what? You stop having feelings you don't understand? No.
所有笑话都始于内部笑话，在某个人的头脑中。有些传到了世界上并流行起来，这就是喜剧，通常工作的方式。这是一个罕见的机会去为另一种笑话加油——那种无人理解的起点，包括你自己。你的理性大脑可以提出理性的争论，然后呢？你停止产生你不理解的感觉吗？不。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program. Tig Notaro's book, I'm Just a Person, came out last summer.
南希·厄普代克是我们的制作人之一。蒂格·诺塔罗的书《我只是一个人》去年夏天出版。
Act Three, Earth Angel.
第三幕，地球天使。
So we close today's program with this story about somebody who sees and believes something that nobody else does. From Etgar Keret, it's read for us by actor Alex Karpovsky.
所以我们用这个故事来结束今天的节目，关于一个看到并相信别人都不信的东西的人。来自埃特加·凯雷特的作品，由演员亚历克斯·卡波夫斯基为我们朗读。
On Bernadette Avenue, right next to the central bus station, there's a hole in the wall. There used to be an ATM there once, but it broke or something, or else nobody ever used it. So the people from the bank came in a pickup and took it and never brought it back. Somebody once told Udi that if you scream a wish into this hole, it comes true. But Udi didn't really buy that.
在伯纳黛特大街，中央汽车站旁边，墙上有个洞。那儿曾经有个自动取款机，但它坏了之类的，或者没人用它。所以银行的人开着皮卡把它带走了，再也没带回来。有人曾告诉乌迪，如果你对着这个洞尖叫一个愿望，它就会实现。但乌迪并不怎么相信。
The truth is that once, on his way home from the movies, he screamed into the hole in the wall that he wanted Daphne Remalt to fall in love with him, and nothing happened. And once, when he was feeling really lonely, he screamed into the hole in the wall that he wanted to have an angel for a friend. And an angel really did show up right after that, but he was never much of a friend. And he'd always disappear just when Udi really needed him.
事实是，有一次在电影院回家的路上，他对着墙洞尖叫，希望达芙妮·雷马尔特爱上他，什么也没发生。还有一次，当他感到非常孤独时，他对着墙洞尖叫，希望有一个天使做朋友。在那之后确实出现了一个天使，但他从来没做过什么好朋友。他总是在乌迪最需要他的时候消失。
This angel was skinny and all stooped, and he wore a trench coat the whole time to hide his wings. People in the street were sure he was a hunchback. Sometimes when they were just the two of them, he'd take the coat off. Once, he even let Udi touch the feathers on his wings, but when there was anyone else in the room, he always kept it on. Kids asked him once what he had under his coat, and he said it was a backpack full of books that didn't belong to him and that he didn't want them to get wet.
这个天使又瘦又驼背，他一直穿着一件风衣来遮住翅膀。街上的人都确信他是个驼子。有时当只剩下他们俩时，他会脱掉外套。有一次，他甚至让乌迪摸了他翅膀上的羽毛，但只要屋里有其他人，他总是穿着外套。孩子们曾经问他外套底下有什么，他说是一个塞满了不属于他的书的背包，他不想让它们被弄湿。
Actually, he lied all the time. He told Udi such stories you could throw up-- about places in heaven; about people who, when they go to bed at night, leave the keys in the ignition; about cats who aren't afraid of anything and don't even know the meaning of scat. The stories he made up were something else. And to top it all, he'd cross-his-heart-and-hope-to-die.
其实，他一直在撒谎。他告诉乌迪那些能让你吐的故事——关于天堂里的地方；关于那些晚上睡觉时不拔钥匙的人；关于那些什么都不怕、甚至不知道“害怕”是什么意思的猫。他编造的故事是独一无二的。最重要的是，他还总发誓绝无虚言。
Udi was nuts about him and always tried hard to believe him, even lent him some money a couple of times when he was hard up. As for the angel, he didn't do a thing to help Udi. He just talked and talked and talked, rambling off his harebrained stories. In the six years he knew him, Udi never saw him so much as rinse a glass.
乌迪对他着了迷，总是努力去相信他，甚至在天使手头紧的时候还借给他几次钱。至于那个天使，他没帮过乌迪任何忙。他只是喋喋不休地胡说八道。在他认识他的六年里，乌迪从来没见过他哪怕冲一下玻璃杯。
When Udi was in the army in basic training and really needed someone to talk to, the angel suddenly disappeared on him for two solid months. Then he came back with an unshaven, don't-ask-what-happened face. So Udi didn't ask, and on Saturday they sat around on the roof in their underpants just taking in the sun and feeling low. Udi looked at the other rooftops with the cable hookups and the solar heaters and the sky. It occurred to him suddenly that, in all their years together, he'd never once seen the angel fly.
当乌迪在军队进行新兵训练，真的需要有人说话时，天使突然对他玩了两个月失踪。然后他带着一张不修边幅、别问发生了什么的脸回来了。所以乌迪没问，星期六他们穿着内裤坐在屋顶晒太阳，心情低落。乌迪看着带有电缆接口和太阳能加热器的其他屋顶，看着天空。他突然想到，在他们在一起的这些年里，他从来没见过这个天使飞行。
"How about flying around a little?" he said to the angel. "It would make you feel better."
“飞一会儿怎么样？”他对天使说，“那会让你感觉好点。”
And the angel said, "forget it. What if someone sees me?"
天使说：“算了吧。要是有人看见我怎么办？”
"Be a sport," Udi nagged. "Just a little. For my sake." But the angel just made this disgusting noise from the inside of his mouth and shot a gob of spit and white phlegm at the tar-covered roof.
“爽快点，”乌迪纠缠道，“就一点。看在我的份上。”但天使只是从嘴里发出那种恶心的噪音，对着柏油屋顶吐了一口口水和白色痰液。
"Never mind," Udi sulked. "I bet you don't know how to fly, anyway."
“算了，”乌迪闷闷不乐，“我敢说你本来就不会飞。”
"Sure I do," the angel shot back. "I just don't want people to see me, that's all."
“我当然会，”天使反驳道，“我只是不想让人看见，仅此而已。”
On the roof across the way they saw some kids throwing a water bomb. "You know," Udi smiled. "Once, when I was little, before I met you, I used to come up here a lot and throw water bombs on people in the street below. I'd aim them into the space between that awning and the other one," he explained, bending over the railing and pointing down at the narrow gap between the awning over the grocery store and the one over the shoe store. "People would look up, and all they'd see was the awning. They wouldn't know where it was coming from."
在对面的屋顶上，他们看到几个孩子在扔水弹。“你知道吗，”乌迪微笑着，“有一次，在我很小的时候，在你认识我之前，我常来这儿扔水弹砸街上的人。我会瞄准那个遮阳篷和另一个遮阳篷之间的空间，”他解释说，弯过栏杆指向杂货店遮阳篷和鞋店遮阳篷之间的狭窄缝隙，“人们向上看，只会看到遮阳篷。他们不知道是从哪来的。”
The angel got up too and looked down into the street. He opened his mouth to say something. Suddenly, Udi gave him a little shove from behind, and the angel lost his balance. Udi was just fooling around. He didn't really mean to hurt the angel, just to make him fly a little, for laughs. But the angel dropped the whole five floors, like a sack of potatoes. Stunned, Udi watched him lying there on the sidewalk below. His whole body was completely still, except the wings, that were still fluttering a little. That's when he finally understood that, of all the things the angel had told him, nothing was true. That he wasn't even an angel, just a liar with wings.
天使也站起来向下望向街道。他张开嘴想说什么。突然，乌迪在背后轻轻推了他一下，天使失去了平衡。乌迪只是在开玩笑。他没想真伤到天使，只是为了好玩，让他飞一点点。但天使像一袋土豆一样直接从五楼摔了下去。惊呆了的乌迪看着他躺在下面的人行道上。他的整个身体一动不动，只有翅膀还在微微抖动。就在那时，他终于明白，天使告诉他的一切，没有一件是真的。他甚至根本不是什么天使，只是一个长着翅膀的骗子。
Alex Karpovsky reading Etgar Keret's story, "Hole in the Wall," which is collected in his book of short stories called The Bus Driver Who Wanted to be God.
亚历克斯·卡波夫斯基朗读埃特加·凯雷特的短篇小说《墙上的洞》，收录于他的短篇小说集《想当上帝的公交车司机》。
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Brian Reed. Editing help for today's show from Joel Lovell and Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Emmanuel Dzotsi and Diane Wu. Research help from Christopher Swetala and Lu Fong. Musical help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天的节目由斯蒂芬妮·傅制作，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。今天节目的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。乔尔·洛弗尔和朱莉·斯奈德提供了编辑帮助。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。伊曼纽尔·佐齐和黛安·吴提供了制作协助。克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和陆丰提供了研究协助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Jeff Emtman, who you heard at the beginning of our program-- the guy who saw a green that was not green-- is the host of Here Be Monsters, a podcast about fear and the unknown from KCRW. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
杰夫·艾特曼，你在我们节目开头听到的那个——那个看到了“绿色的非绿色”的家伙，是《此处有怪兽》（Here Be Monsters）的主持人，这是一档关于恐惧和未知的播客，来自KCRW电台。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。
Support for This American Life comes from Lagunitas Brewing Company, committed to keeping the pub in public radio by offering curious ales and lagers for those who appreciate hearing and telling great stories. Learn more at lagunitas.com.
《美国生活》的支持来自拉古尼塔斯酿造公司，致力于通过为那些欣赏好故事并乐于讲述好故事的人提供好奇的啤酒和拉格，来保持公共广播中的酒吧文化。更多信息请访问lagunitas.com。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he and I were on a flight together this week and we got delayed on the tarmac for three hours. It got to the point where Torey started calling out to the cockpit and heckling the pilot.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的共同创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，这周我和他坐同一班飞机，我们在停机坪上延误了三个小时。到了后来，托里开始对着驾驶舱向飞行员大喊大叫。
How about flying around a little? It would make you feel better.
飞一会儿怎么样？那会让你感觉好点。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。